well we're going to begin this hour in a
musical note with our road to the Tony's
coverage where we count down to
Broadway's biggest night the Tony Awards
air June 11th right here on CBS This
Morning Anthony Mason is giving us a
behind-the-scenes look at one of
Broadway's hottest new shows the
critically acclaimed musical Kimberly
akimbo is up for eight Awards this year
including best musical and best original
score lin-manuel Miranda called it a
miracle and said he left the show Happy
sobic love that Anthony spoke with the
cast and creators to find out why it is
resonating with so many people Anthony
good morning good morning such a great
show and the three actors we spoke to
are all up for Tony Awards what's even
more remarkable each nearly turned down
a chance to audition for the show
you had to be persuaded to take this
part it was a daunting Prospect I want
to be a model for a day
a famous fashion Muse to take on the
role
of a young girl who's on the brink of
Womanhood but who's also facing the end
of her life Victoria Clark plays
Kimberly lavacco a 15 year old with a
fictional condition that causes her to
age prematurely
everyone will stare at me but not in the
usual way a veteran of Broadway shows
this is my 13th Lucky 13 I hope Clark is
up for a Tony for a role she was
reluctant to take how hard did they have
to persuade you
period of months actually was it
I'm a classically trained lyric soprano
yeah and this is a teenager
[Music]
Clark
plays a character who's mentally younger
but physically older
that's an interesting trick it is it's
living both
streams of your own life in one Spectrum
but in the midst of all that it's daring
the audience to live in the present I
like the way you look at life and think
outside the box a little odd a little
off a bit unworthod Kimberly finds a
kindred spirit in Seth Kimberly Lavaca
turns into
loves anagrams cleverly
akimbo Seth is played by 19 year old
Justin Cooley cleverly akimbo who's
making his Broadway debut and you get a
Tony nomination yeah yeah I can't
believe it either it's kind of
mind-blowing really crazy Cooley who's
from Kansas was offered the role after
he made the finals
[Music]
of a National High School theater
contest
but
kind of reluctant to take this part
yes yes so I knew I didn't have like the
experience and all of the years of
training and skill that I thought I
would have needed to pull something like
this off but he has this time I think I
found a friend how does that feel by the
way
this this feels crazy I remember the
first time I saw it it was like a little
emotional
Bonnie Milligan whose big voice brings
down the house in Kimberly akimbo is
also up for a Tony she too almost passed
on her part I didn't feel like I could I
had just lost my father to pancreatic
cancer but her mom helped her make her
audition tape she hit play on that
computer for me to sing my first song
and
um I got it like the next day it was
crazy Milligan plays Kimberly's Crazy
Aunt Debra a lovable con artist
advice to take advantage of sick old
ladies no
not just them whose skin games include
stealing a mailbox
you play an ant to encourages children
to commit check fraud
ible yeah
Milligan grew up in a trailer in the
midwest what's funny is I remember
saying when I was in high school I don't
know if I have a voice
when life gives you
[Music]
I love things but I got into college and
that's where I really started belting
[Music]
and you know you talk about my voice my
voice comes from my dad and so I carry
him with me in such
apparent ways on stage and I think the
initial clinging to Kimberly was Bonnie
wanting to cling to someone who was
going and feeling all the love I could
critics and crowds have reigned Love On
the Musical and fans keep coming back I
find myself so tremendously moved by her
hope because it's so life-affirming in
spite of everything that's going on I've
seen it 14 times tonight I think I
connect to it so much because I relate
to the characters in the show so much
yeah I love the different outcasts of
society because I kind of felt like that
when I was in high school too that
really is hitting different audiences in
a way that certainly nothing I've ever
done has hit Pulitzer Prize winner David
Lindsay a bear wrote the original play
more than 20 years ago it's also really
gratifying because it's a weird little
show it is a weird little show yeah life
is weird five six seven eight
and at the urging of Tony winning
composer Janine to sorry they turned it
into a musical mapping out Kimberly's
Journey on a cork board in the sort of
run-up to the show how much does this
move around oh my God it's like Scrabble
from the very beginning we knew that we
were not writing a story about a girl
that was dying we were writing a story
about a girl that was desperately trying
to live heartbreak and
um and Joy are they sit right next to
each other
[Music]
people literally walk out of this show
in tears yeah that's our favorite
I think our story is about
what will it take for you to stop and
realize how precious life is yeah and
there is a catharsis there is a release
that I personally feel every night and I
think the audience does too
[Music]
those performances all of them
extraordinary Victoria Clark absolutely
amazing in in a really difficult
performance playing a teenager and an
older person at the same time you can
imagine I can only imagine and I and the
fact that people are going back over and
over again to see this musical is
remarkable in this day and it's funny
because it is one of those shows it's
very hard to describe what it's about
and initially you think it must be sad
but it's not and it's everything what
Janine said it's it's you know it's it's
touching on the one hand because it's it
is sad in one hand but it's also very
optimistic in another what she said
there it's not the story about a girl
dying it's about a girl trying to live
that made me go that's why the tears
it's not it's not sad there's the happy
tears those are the you learn something
in that moment yeah it's a weird little
show but life is weird life is weird and
one of the things I love about some of
my favorite shows are shows that are
it's very hard to describe the plot like
Hades town for example dear Evan Hansen
yeah this is one of those shows it's a
small show it's not a huge production
but it's got a massive heart and that's
what everybody's feeling cannot wait
yeah Anthony thank you so much Kimberly
Kimbo currently playing as you know it's
at the booth theater on Broadway and be
sure to watch the 76th annual Tony
Awards June 11th at 8 pm Eastern right
here on CBS and streaming on Paramount
Kimberly Kimbo eight nominations
including best musical looking forward
to that